David can you explain in the context of
your views on free speech which content
should not be allowed on social networks
okay so my view on this is basically law
plus logic okay there are a lot of
different views about when should
content be removed from social networks
and oftentimes there is a total jumble
of legal arguments moral arguments
arguments that use the term free speech
in a completely wrong way so let's kind
of lay out my perspective on this my
starting point is unless the content is
illegal then it should in principle be
allowed on unless it falls under certain
categories of behavior or speech that a
social network as a private business
should have the ability and I would
argue responsibility to keep off of its
network so if the content is illegal it
should be pulled period no questions
asked
next we get to stuff like targeted
bullying and harassment of individuals I
don't want if I were running a social
network I would not want my social
network to be in any way associated with
perpetuating these cycles of people who
are attacked and targeted on the
Internet
and then it bleeds over into their real
lives sometimes people become suicidal
there are people who have actually taken
their own lives because of bullying that
was happening in great part online so
that it can't be used as a tool for
targeted harassment in that way in the
same way that if you follow someone
around in real life much in the same way
that is taking place online even if
you're not stalking them per se if
you're constantly attacking them and
insulting them and yelling things at
them you would be able to call the
police and the police would tell that
person you've got to go there is no
legal issue with social network saying
that's not going to be the way that you
can use this tool that's number one
number two it is perfectly reasonable
for social networks to say even though
it is now
illegal to target people on the basis of
their immutable characteristics
sometimes in membership in what in some
states are called protected classes we
are not going to allow it on the
platform and again if I was running a
social network I would not want to see
the platform used to target individuals
or to attack individuals on the basis of
their religion their ethnicity their
sexual orientation or whatever the case
may be I wouldn't allow it on my social
network if you don't like that then you
can go and either build a different
social network or find a different one
or Lobby the social network to change
those rules but that's essentially my my
thinking I don't think that there is any
responsibility of a social network to
block conspiracy articles or anything
like that I think once you start taking
money to promote things like for example
the wrong voting day via advertising the
way Facebook has been facing lately I
think that's a different question but in
principle if you're posting some kind of
conspiracy or fake news article as an
individual if it's not attacking or
pushing bullying on individuals if it's
not attacking or harassing people on the
basis of their membership in some
protected class or a mutable
characteristic I think that that's fine
I don't think that social networks
should get involved in policing that but
but those would be my parameters
essentially illegal content is not
allowed targeted harassment bullying and
encouragement of bullying both online
and in-person against people should not
be allowed and attacks on people that
are either race-based nationality
attacks on people with with disabilities
for example I wouldn't allow any of that
stuff on my social network let me know
what you think we've got a great bonus
show coming up for you today become a
member instantly at join pakman.com and
you will get access just as instantly to
the world-famous bonus show